yeah
so I'll read the chat and then ask you
some questions and bug you were you
trying to play no that's way that's my
job okay do you want to talk first term
well we can start I mean okay they're
already I mean I'm ready to start
already
on three minutes just to give them more
time more playing time all right yeah so
yeah we're definitely alive we're here
with the great autonomous coleauxv
Grandmaster here to crush people today
hopefully well just mainly put it fun
have fun
what yeah sounds like a good idea so
we'll have a little bit fun we'll play
some people looks like there's already
quite a lot challengers I guess I knew
you were we're coming
is there any time control that you're
looking for here today no mainly three
minutes but okay yeah let's stop hey
cheap here arrrooo - good to see you
guys in the chat this not this time with
people okay and we will see alright and
so this also could be funny because
people are we have two big event the
Karen's Cup coming up so you may hear
people in the background doing a little
bit of busy work so Dennis LaRue will be
sneaking in yeah yeah come on in guys so
you guys here for Karen's Cup we do have
snacks so you don't want to miss it come
and join us
since you're a little bit odd that black
didn't play t5 t6 hey you didn't get in
you're popular they've seen you before
oh yeah Wow Jeep was waiting for the
stream two hours before well good to
have you hopefully you put your
challenge in you'll be at the top of the
list yeah don't tell her it's funny or
that way this was not expected yeah this
looks promising for you
why is the board looks like yellow does
it look all yellow again today I don't
know what they're saying you guys know
what they're saying rub the board
looking all yellow and they were saying
that yesterday cuz I don't see it on the
street but it might be it must be a
thing
I can play this yeah nice little fork
down because boy that there was like the
bishop hanging on a torso to be easy
joy say a little bit louder on the mic
well they always like turn our volume
down they mute us they think whatever
they do they're so funny hey bumblebee
oh yeah can we send the link to
challenge you have someone someone could
spam the link there for you but yeah
we're playing on Lee chess challenge st.
Louis chess club someone will put the
link there in the chat just a second and
yeah so we're looking for mostly three
minutes today seems to be a good one so
I guess we're starting with the rating
of about 1985 we took a dip under 2000
but hopefully we get some rate of
challenges and pumped that rating back
up
so do have a serious question already if
your seems like a reasonable time to
start answering some questions what can
you do if you start losing motivation to
play I think there's actually a typical
problem maybe you should take like a
rest and then try to find like we are
motivation I mean okay it's about the
love of the game
like every other activity I mean you
just really have to like it because it's
becoming boring and then maybe I should
change right she's just saying hi to
Danny and his friends Danny seems to be
a popular guy even though he's never on
the street they have a lot of fun back
there mostly that guy that yeah it needs
to get them out are you gonna make a
physical presence today
alright thanks Jarek for the kind words
this is day 4 in the Spanish but now
he's taking too much time I'll play one
system which I like you know not to
change the bishop the bishop goes to d7
3 is equal to 6
this should be done
all right so we do have another serious
question here from cobalt-blue
animations of endgame opening and
tactics which one would you say is the
biggest thing that separates an 1,800
rated player from a 2,000 rated player
enough maybe bolt
I mean needs difficult assignment
probably tactics mom yeah I feel like
I'm in that range and I definitely say
tactics that seems to be why I win or
lose games
[Music]
yeah do tactics stargher is wondering
what your main openings are no it was
used to be Syrian nowadays probably 500
often but okay you're supposed to play
e5 in the person it's not like surprise
you make the switch
well it's kind of a gift more chances
because when you play open tournament so
you need you know more chances for the
three results as I code
[Music]
so a controversial question what are
your opinions on the French defense well
I'm not very fond of defend defend but
okay it's a good opening if you know it
quite well you have to really know it
because you play most of the pishon with
less space so you've got to be familiar
where we have with the standard position
and to enjoy them yeah I know some you
know relatively strong players they just
like hate the French I just like say you
can't really play that it's just really
bad I've played it seem to enjoy if I'm
sort of switching to society
hey congrats to Jarek who today became
the middle school chess club champion
congratulations no my bishop sometimes
is hanging but I kind of feeling this
should be good and because I don't want
Knight e5 these tactics
they might not know their bishops
attacked yeah he's missing some details
let's play something a little bit safer
I think this Bishop is changing but I
just don't want to know well this is a
little bit resentful all right Thank You
slaughterhouse-five it's been getting
into a lot of these dreams you know
let's go look look yeah just got this
text from Dani asking me where I am
yeah like that was like yeah LTS all
over good hopefully this can help us get
back to mm if we win this okay good to
see you tarik
so I was asking about your opinion of
like the modern demands or the parents
it's not an easy opening to play but I
don't know I mean like those kind of
positions not a great fan of the period
but there are some players like is my
purse really who played to his life and
even got a very famous victory against
Anatoly Karpov you know his best tier so
yeah you see a lot of like 2700 is doing
it when I got a beat 25 26 hundreds and
also nowadays Deponia she used although
on the last time ago still costing a
second yeah but he used it to get like
more complication because he was trying
you know to get like that chance is to
play for a win although it didn't come
out exactly like that but what to learn
other than tactics all your opening
comments
is this a language you can read yeah
this is slice congratulation from
Bulgaria these from my hometown what is
that what's nice cows and mm-hmm what's
nice go here saying but congratulations
from Boger yes LM is a bit of a an
upgrade from GM there's far fewer LMS
out there in the world Luigi
[Music]
we consider playing three two I think
[Music]
[Music]
what's with all the banging we are
actually right underneath the kingside
diner and so it's sort of when they're
they're closing up right now yeah this
is real life you get to see people you
know come in the studio we do actually a
lot of work out of here when we're we're
not you know doing the big productions
you can see that people are doing
bringing in snacks and water and the
drinks and that's everything you can
hear upstairs
you know we're under the diner this is
real life that's why we stream give you
a little little sneak behind the scenes
here we're not gonna get this experience
the ambiance during an actual tournament
or something so it's good you guys get
to see it a little bit now all right
he's back but he's really quiet we don't
know who he is
[Music]
you think people have realized that we
now have snacks again whatever is
happening here we're certainly doing it
faster yeah yeah we're doing well okay
then I go back with the Bishop from BIA
one no okay so it's not like a big
problem yeah we're actually right
underneath a bowling alley that's a good
point Joe slammin
what's your favorite opening with way
I don't know every favorite opening I
mean I play d4 I've played almost all of
the the normal opening lines
keep the birds opening us play ball
yeah hey okay
doing well
all right good to see you love hey chess
Sicilian Chinese dragon yeah very
acceptable when Julian Pro Lego was here
definitely that was just go to when he
played the dragon some years ago maybe
he still does it let's see somebody okay
and it's bleedy for this thing
completely frozen in here nope Etha yeah
it's been quite quite cold the last
couple days are you doing Thomas Scott
from the llama Lord this is Caleb this
is a sting opening line
caleb is one to know what's the worst
opening you still see at the GM level I
mean I really question I don't see many
better opening for the GM level yes what
bad is is kind of varies by level well
this should not be a very good opening
well basically this would be a very bad
opening and why is it the Banco gambit
yeah why is the curse it was given very
good result
yeah okay playing against the Banco I
think people with realized on the
streamers right here probably a little
bit of combination can I have not so bad
check reason this site because they call
this people don't work at leech s called
us
if he sim yeah becomes juice
this becomes more and more dubious
oh yeah the answer to Thomas Scott's
photo someone here should know I know
Ben Simon knows the name of the music in
the intro into all of our like YouTube
videos and stuff it's something I know
it was made for like been fine gold so
it's called like Ben's song and I think
it was not Ben Simon but Ben Feingold
it's called that for it was something
that was like custom-made for us I think
that's what's called the s-pen Simon
Ben's round it's called yeah and I
believe was named after Ben fine go cuz
he was like the jammin res here forever
so if someone does not play then we wait
a little bit yeah this is the chaos and
then that's important yeah no good trick
that's like casual there's some likes
somebody's a really long games you know
I mean three minutes I'm looking they're
here this way
I've got still don't see hey you Ray you
said theoretical oh good yeah you're
probably guys you'll be able to watch
this on our YouTube channel after this
if you're unable to watch the rest of it
we'll think about considering some
five-oh games if they pop up
seems like three oh is the awaiting
choice though
came here
okay good thanks too much this may may
be a problem yeah don't get scared of
gussto just play your best
do you have a guess on who the next
World Championship Challenger might be
if you had to guess
yeah Fabi always has good chances I
think Tingler in has good chances some
other good players everyone has a chance
yeah the rating has gone up quite a bit
back over 2000
I don't know what our peak is on the
same story drop the piece yeah I mean
sometimes it happens
was it I wasn't watching first okay damn
I'll flip okay I can't take give them a
take back if it's possible you get the
check mark if you really must look
beautiful
yeah yeah yeah if you eat that it was it
okay so let's connect so I mean I can't
even I don't want to reason okay yeah
obviously I'll give ya a chance to take
that back
Livan could be the next one Graham Nick
will probably not be the next one yeah
but I just made the mob slip and then he
just waits to all of his time yeah so
went back a half loops you have to give
him one more to say yeah it only goes
back a half move so yeah now he's asking
for the take back let's see if one gets
oh yes yes except that you don't go back
a half we might go back how did you yeah
yeah just check mark this okay there we
go
you got your book bag under okay he just
wanted a little bit extra time to think
you know he just was waiting to accept
it but yeah I thought the other day the
stream was trolling me they said crime
Nick retired yeah this is like how do
you feel about it you know and I thought
they were just meant oh he had such a
bad tournament okay I'm just joking with
me but no childress not playing better
if you read some of his latest
interviews he was saying that probably
he won't play like too many just exactly
when he was protocol saying that you'll
play around like maybe four or five
years more so basically he kept his word
ya know because
is the sound low did you guys actually
lower it on us
peace okay look I shouldn't have given
you slip back because you plan scary why
you played you played two too long okay
I proposed to play with this value
why should there's something there's
some button on there if you accidentally
hit it it does that thing on the screen
I don't know what it is I want to play
next people help
what does I don't know Danny Isaac maybe
click on it again yeah here comes the
tech crew to save the day
look at this so he's clicking on the
challenge button and then it just spins
and spins it like nothing exploded
because you saw how we just had that
leaf HD on page thing just refresh
everything yeah that's this one
Colin wardrobe 204 which one of us yeah
complaining so I do have a guest - based
on your wardrobe who you're voting for
this weekend you'll be watching the
Super Ball
the rims out okay tech guy name please
his name is Danny what you got
move the extra background chair well
Dennis LaRue shows up where is he gonna
sit tech guy social number is one two
three four
[Music]
mother's maiden name is
I love the Lord plain Caleb here
it's very famous for their freedom self
this is good I'll get to learn how to
crush Caleb
I mean no doubt about it
how do you feel about their three names
oh I've looked at it some time ago so
I'm quite confident about this position
especially this should be good well I
don't know about this move last one only
not great one
this is a good position I mean my king
is safer and I have a lot of squares and
I mean there was a grandmasters Clank
wish to play this line I prepared for
him although it never happened so I gave
to be honest never happened you know
game but still this
yes this is Caleb Debbie who works here
at the club and is sometimes on the
stream that you playing here
yeah well known f3 nimza player
Oh Caleb did a very nice premiere
yesterday showing tactics that's right
okay okay
just
he's a great place first he definitely
does the I know it's as if to give him
that yeah I think it's blitz writing
isn't like the twenty-four twenty-five
hundred range
he's also a master of the coordinates
trainer he's gotten some crazy high
scores
this was not great
[Music]
returning something
we got a crush gave up
I isn't it it's not a checkmate
well giftings here a little bit
not much time
yeah the drama is building
let's gonna try to flank you
okay
yeah well good job Caleb yeah
that's why these guys you know play when
they don't resign
all right good good game Caleb
next time not so fast please
this is for waiting for Zen
hopefully I gave you what you need
the book this is quite curious
yeah just I was wondering what I what
you had for dinner last night
I think that's nothing before and I just
can't remember you know give the people
that one have you been eating a lot
around here
[Music]
what was your favorite chess era they
want to know
beautiful
Oh favorite rusev yeah we have a new
class now where you go over games from
the Romantic era I like to look but I
don't I can't say that it's like a
favorite
what was your reaction when Kasparov
lost the deep-blue no not surprised I
mean personally quite strong
hey past pond I'm doing pretty good
prease loved watching from Bulgaria
it's white much better here
it's that way to me
dun er Washington from because NECA Stan
good to have you
we have to be concentrated this time
control because miss julia doesn't give
you a lot of time to joke around I
haven't heard this rumor I think as far
off was paid to lose the match against
igloo
did you rumor I haven't heard you're not
buying it
not carlson's been real close he's
obviously been the closest to 2,900
obviously in classical and other things
that's definitely possible to reach like
3000 he could do it I mean he said he's
in good form now that you played the
World Championship so yeah I couldn't I
could see it happening Thomas Scott he's
presumably a photographer
cuz his name on the chat is Thomas Scott
photos
geom coleauxv it's very focused this is
why he plays a lot better than everyone
else on the stream
is it possible to play him yeah if we
can get someone to throw the thing back
up in the chat with the Lynx blasts
we're here on Lee chess anyone can
challenge us we're playing the people
just go to Lee chest challenge st. Louis
chess club in a minute there'll be the
link there posted in the chat so yeah
we're playing mostly three minutes a day
so if you're looking to get a challenge
in I suggest that time to draw
this looks good for us
yeah I hear you Dennis
I'm watching from Turkey yeah waiting
for one hour Severo sniffs five and why
is the link not lit up don't know but if
you copy paste that it'll it'll get you
in there
you try three two but yeah three Oh is
your best chance trying to play a lot of
games today
so yeah it's a cool thing we got people
from everywhere watching today very cool
hey you gonna go in the stream yeah come
on if you're coming in you're grabbing
stuff you gotta get on the stream
are you getting on the stream come on
people love you yeah all your favorites
are here but they're all behind the
scenes
can you play even if you're just a
beginner yes of course yeah everyone's
welcome to come in play us we're playing
the people some people have higher
ratings than others that doesn't matter
we'll play anybody Yaser is coming into
town yeah and the next couple days go
sir I'll be here how can i play you the
link was just posted hopefully you
caught it but otherwise go to Li chests
and look for a st. Louis chess club you
guys can find us there challenged us to
a game and there's the link again the
stream is from where we are so we're on
Twitch I'm also a euro obviously
chatting in the youtube over here I'm
watching the chat in YouTube and on
Twitch and we're playing on a chess
yeah we'll be doing some live lectures
on YouTube
let me see I'm gonna allow this somebody
so these messages get held that have
nothing no kinda DNA but we're gonna
start doing some live lecture so you
might get to see that very soon Danny
what's the first live lecture we need
headsets so he can you know just tell me
right into my ear but yeah some that's
what I want to do it yeah well there's
gonna be some during Karen's cup there's
gonna be live lectures right like the
regular lectures were doing throughout
the week but why is that they're talking
about yeah maybe that's what they mean I
don't know but we're gonna do I don't
know the people know they know more
about us than we know about us a lot of
the time what is the at the shortest
match you lost as a grandmaster and
about match for game is
because also we also have a new show
here to my grants losses so I'm sure
you'll get to see all the best games
he's ever lost
unfortunately
yeah that's why I have to be focused
yellow dragoon is asking how do you
approve at the 2300 grading range you
have any tips for that 20 so he's about
2300
how does he approve it about that range
yeah very good
now also you keep working on chespin all
the phases so really without knowing the
person it's very difficult to give like
a general Glasgow chase but you I think
that the basic is to invest the maximum
amount of time like in every other area
if you keep working and put the effort
there'll be a progress for sure I really
am not aware of any kind of a special
received but really it depends on the
individual you have to be familiar with
his games and then maybe you can give
like a modern quit advisement least what
was it was there anything special for
you like what for you personally was it
the took you from 23 to really like a
long time ago I really don't remember
him this level probably hit like a
junior but I really don't have a
recollection I mean this was like more
than 30 years ago
J gets more difficult note to be jammed
these days due to all the engines and
all that sort of stuff
well I don't think I think it no to you
is it the same is it
yeah I think it is you
yeah maybe I'm more qualified to say how
to improve at the 1600 level that's more
my speed
yeah I think it's a lot of a lot of
tactics that's a lot of just playing too
so play a lot of dealership tactics you
know and watching things like this
especially when you got grandmasters
playing I think is a is a huge way to
improve as well so there's there's also
a million resources where you can watch
stronger players playing online and you
can kind of understand their if their
thought process and stuff
yes this guy's provisional so we don't
know how good he really is
so this is the the 2300 asking again do
you think semi Slav is a good opening
these days to fight for a win with black
especially the the Bishop g5 crazy lens
yeah you know it quite well and all the
arising bone structures why not yeah I'm
a big fan of the semi Slav all right
tell me Scott photos is indeed a
photographer thank goodness we got to
the bottom of that and yeah so
presumably you can go find his its
portfolio somewhere on the internet if
you're interested play hyper billet it's
easy
yeah thank you for the game Scott
what's up to e4 e5 hf6
what do you think of the London system
well it's quite curious that I have to
analyze my idea playing this system and
try to a student of mine which I worked
a couple of years ago and because you
didn't study Jessie at home so I have to
shock an interesting system and I've
included the Llano system but in my way
of playing it in a much more active
different way so I think it's a good one
to get as tired as some people do some
people are really tired of it yeah
because I've worked my thumb really but
I've kind of played differently then
after that it became popular I can't be
played it with you yes yours mine was
c4c touch tarik
you can challenge to hyper no uh no
promise that will accept it but you can
challenge
if you guys are gonna make jokes out
there why don't you bring it in here so
we can hear them alright
what if they're really good jokes we're
missing out on that is anyone out there
that wants to come in
[Music]
yeah challenge us for good I recommend
three minute though yeah get in here
Dennis everybody wants to see you you in
particular if you're the only one
they'll come in presumably no some days
when you got millions of people then
everyone like swarms in and then some
days everyone's like no I'm not going on
the camera today but dancer you got a
you had all your hair yesterday and now
something is gone yeah something's
changed about you yes it's this one say
yes some days it's that one so this is
it's right here though I know they throw
you off they'll do anything how long is
this stream so we got at least 30 to 40
more minutes left
yeah we want Paul on stream that's no
read right here we want Paul on stream
for nickerson yeah it's a lot my lord
but nobody's speaking for everyone in
the chat all right come on Paul Paul a
riot
Wow come on Joe slime wants to see you
Joe slime no you don't know him come in
he's been waiting to see you yeah
awesome haircut Thanks
thank you looking good is that was that
with the other Karen's Cup coming up in
mind or you just need a haircut
Paul get in here so what are you working
on there Paul people want to see this
real life is what we do here ready for
the big show the people all right this
is what Paul does this is what we do we
move soda from one place to another
definitely will have snacks so if I get
the $10 ticket I get soda all day is
that part of the deal as much as you
will Paul serve it to me personally no
no but you will get the soda will not be
served by Paul that's good to know
all right your haircuts 10 out of 10 by
the way thank you no I'm actually yeah
we will deny this kind of game going on
here yeah no red ball yeah no you know
that red ball you do you drink one
coffee a day is there like a strict no
is it just one is it like a strict well
I don't know why your wife is always
better but I mean you have to play fast
waiting for Sam what sure is that your
name on on this site waiting for Zen
he's it's late in Norway he's got to go
to work tomorrow maybe we can find the
next game for you after we know your
handle
we are close to me but the camera
doesn't know that no yeah we have this
chair and then they said move that chair
away cuz but I'm like what's the room it
looks like I'm way closer to you are
thank you no it doesn't look weird
though on my arch and you actually look
really cool I like it yeah thanks
privacy you're very welcome for all the
lectures on YouTube
which Dutch were you looking at that you
never finished with well there's a three
part series so we never covered the main
line yeah I'm going to lose no but don't
get us
I also like the Dennises in the middle
these yeah look up there so you know
what we look like where you are
hey fairy lord let's see it's a long
comment but it looks like it's all good
stuff about me thank you very much come
on we got to get this guy
this yeah we got it
wonderful concentration because you know
there's a guy waiting for Zen is his
name he's gotta go to work if you lose
good waiting presentable for you and if
he's on that list but from the find him
next cuz he's been he's been in the chat
yeah there's all these shortcut keys on
the mouse so yeah anything there's like
a hundred ways you can mess it up with
the mouse here he yeah I agree with you
though although I have to admit after
playing with her for a while it got kind
of it felt nice it felt a little
different a little smoother moving the
pieces around yeah pick me I crash you I
can play you if you're gonna crush us
that's not fair
[Music]
yeah it's quite comfortable there's just
a lot of what if we can disable all the
secret buttons on it
so you can't mess anything up
it takes to the Queen you're just gonna
play Rupp d8 is that what this is good
everything I mean it's like a mouthful
right head over to your rook I wasn't
sure if you're going to take with you
this isn't going too far
No
where's your GM title yeah so we were
actually upgraded to LM it's an upgrade
they are they don't give out the title
anymore but somehow we were able to just
get in there and snag one and it's much
rarer than the GM title so it's a high
honor
yeah yeah thousands can be GM mirror
dozens can be LM and we're one of them
so yeah is it's a big achievement how do
we feel about been leaving st. Louis you
know he's got to do what he's gonna do
he's obviously a great his stream was
great always and you know seems like
he's he's doing well and I'm happy for
him so hopefully he comes back at some
point says hi he's come back at least
once or twice and he's come in he said
hi everything's cool
so this I guess is a question more for
you than me how do you treat a bad
tournament psychologically while it's
still in progress if you're having a bad
tournament how do you deal with it in
the middle of the tournament we have to
see what is the reason for your birth
plan and try to eradicate it if it's
possible it's not a focus you you try to
get better focus the concentration the
guy waiting for Zen this one they're
waiting for soon okay here we go yeah
yeah let's try to sneak this one in
hopefully he's still there yeah this
person has been in our camp for not just
today but like all the time so and the
good news for us is it's late in Norway
so it's very tired and we'll crush them
that's the plan
it's Bensimon a grandmaster not at the
moment
mm-hmm oh so what is your name mean I
see your name all the time I want to
pronounce it I just don't even know
where to start
like Spurs anacs kind of idea
so this is how you play the London yeah
yeah
try to play this thing I love them
what's my pink rating like 1970 1970
ex tries an ex trike times Zen next rise
in got it good to see extras in
next rise annex then maybe I don't have
it too complicated
all right welcome back Jerry
mmm
interesting
you couldn't lose it couldn't move in
the last game because of connection
that's a shame
dylan-esque and when we started playing
chess I started in college I was until I
was like I know 21 or something
I started playing chess did you start at
a very early age then did you start in
school no nowaday should attend they are
quite a very good so it's we can say
that it's late a little bit
[Music]
checking off this should be versus
and then I believe also tonight is the
we're doing our thing at at 8:00 p.m.
tonight right it's the first ever ladies
night tonight so after this the stream
will get going hopefully Dan is coming
out to tell us a little bit about it we
got you know 20 to 30 more minutes here
and then come back at 8 o'clock we have
our ladies night streamer what does it
mean
nobody knows come at 8 o'clock check it
out
who's your favorite world champion
maybe point fish yeah
alright CI Derek Derek says by wishes
you good luck it's also the new money
ting presented well I think positional I
know
this is what I do for a living well you
just got some for yourself huh there's
that for me or what's what's going on
here in charge of this yeah yes the
company okay now when you come back tell
me about the the ladies night stream the
thing it ate because it starts tonight
right is she there coz she's doing it
right are these streams new haven't
noticed it before yeah they're
relatively new so we're getting to go in
so this is I think only the third GM
stream we're adding streams all the time
so we have a new one coming in so we're
gonna have hopefully Emily Trask coming
in here soon to give us a little bit of
info about it but well yes or didn't get
into the streams and here she is
Emily Trask yeah right there yeah so we
got this new stream tonight at 8:00 p.m.
if they can see they see it on their
thing there it's called ladies night
what is it exactly - they don't know
anything about it was planned I will be
playing the night with Danny but you go
oh cool think of it as Danny but you're
playing is that true Danny Danny please
I don't know he knew how to play and
then our here begin our instructor her
daughter plays in our scholastic
tournaments okay look at that Emily
comes down and look at this hunter bits
thank you good job Emily her daughter is
seven years old and she's going to so
I'll sit we're at honest - sitting
she'll sit we're easy sitting and Danny
will probably be off on the side yeah
okay that makes sense um in the next
week Eevee will be where I'm she'll be
playing so people can play a
seven-year-old oh I know but hopefully
she crushes everyone good yeah that'll
be exciting so that's less than four
hours from now so whatever time zone
you're in definitely wanna check that
one out
check quick ask her a question otherwise
she might leave thanks Emily the pair of
Bishops approved
yeah eight oh yeah let's play for ya
Danny that's it rumor is you're on the
show and then I guess it's just you
playing Jess can we call it ladies night
let's play scotch okay what what so
what's your take up night break out of
that
did you it was here and it was hot and I
drink out of it is that yours yeah did
you drink out of this at all I need at
least two so this will get me through
the next ten minutes all right
sorry about that is is there is there no
more new my bed I mean I figured I tell
you instead of you know poisoning you
hey Bobby's
I know I I'm not expecting to be heard
for the rest of the show but at least I
have my coffee
[Music]
checkmate or a nice going to g4 I guess
what's good noggin is enjoy my coffee
without people looking at me that's
that's much better than Jenny perfect
large improvement to the stream is this
possible at all no I just can't believe
that no I mean why should I
[Music]
[Music]
what's the problem
should be having more space why the pawn
is 185 this is the question
I am surprised I can take tonight we
worried about something I just didn't
want to read because maybe a little bit
of you know be sure so I mean I don't
see why positionally I'm why the pawn on
h5 is any benefit for black no I mean
they know they can't curse also it
should be like all these sacrifices I
mean positionally they are trying to to
get some sort of compensation for some
positional indicates they're not they're
opening okay comfy
I'm probably also on all top of all the
cords - but nothing worried about it
Oh sacrifice again exists this time I
really not into the mood of not taking a
right yes they give you enough chances I
guess we don't take it sometimes just
turn this so I can read more greetings
from Bulgaria
okay
like us long-term compensation
seems doubtful it's very hard to believe
that I mean there may be some kind of
Oh
she's becoming to long-term composition
maybe a bit too much
yeah we know it was a joke
hey I'm gonna straight-up chillin in
here - what's up what's up what's going
on there's a nice relaxed stream we got
this game is casual no they're not
stealing this person's rating points all
right
mighty juice jewels [ __ ] him down this
is rated that's what we want
she's a little bit reluctant to start
maybe getting a coffee something we have
to put him to a doping test before I can
move okay I mean just some time you see
this was about coffee knew you were
coming there tax amount was about coffee
now a second coffee
hey this is yeah now it's not the time
to start who is it possible to ask for a
dope test these guys take you know ii
[Laughter]
know i mean the opponent juice you know
like 20 seconds to make the first move
you gotta thank 20 seconds just like
this is like a serious chetana I mean he
take professionals don't be afraid play
some chess let's go
we're in effect I like the music of
Atanas koulev the rapper yeah yeah yeah
no I'm the young guy you think you know
someone else it's much less early much
younger than me yeah stylistic wrapping
the Thomas Cole EV
mmm so yeah how do we handle different
playing strengths here in our tournament
some tournaments that you have different
sections and whatever so you know
there's like an under 2000 section under
1,400 section or you know sometimes
there's six sections sometimes there's
one or two sections but oh yeah everyone
just gathers here and right now in the
club I know that there's some people
there you know very brand-new and and
right now there's actually some pretty
decent players upstairs just hanging out
playing chess so it works out pretty
well it doesn't matter where you
strengthes people come to a chess club
to play some chess
[Music]
I'm surprised we took on defy for the
bishop no no
yeah I don't really
everybody's a
it's a little bit worried about this guy
nobody see it
yes
they're asking you what your best game
ever was yeah you played any memorable
games
well not coming now into my own but
probably I've played some not so bad
who's the highest rated person you be
effect which we will check and I didn't
beat them so this is true but I had like
some
like I concentrate on this one because
this guy will is getting a good position
so I got to play a little bit faster
yeah I do hope to get it back at some
point to make an opening videos for
those asking about it in the chat it was
a good time where I had you know plenty
of time I do it I'm only gonna do it if
I can spend quite a bit of time
preparing all the videos I don't want to
just make you know anything bad so for
now I'm just hanging out on Twitch yeah
we got a lot going on here at the club
I'm doing a lot of you know prep for
like Aaron's Cup and all the big events
there's like so many tournaments this
year it's it's gonna be tough but at
some point probably when I get some time
I'll make some some lecturers don't get
on YouTube again yeah so comer tomorrow
probably won't be playing blitz so for
those word about our blitz rating
sinking again you'll probably be doing
bullet again he usually does one oh so
Michael be here I said link will not be
here tomorrow so hopefully there's some
other co-hosts
I gets the chill out and watch Mike play
some amazing bullet games but uh I'm
assuming at least for Friday our blitz
rating will be safe it's the bullet
rating you got to watch out for
especially not Mike's the only one
that's ever played bullet on there so
whatever that is is what it may explode
rating us thank you yeah but the opening
didn't play quite well I mean after
having a good position but okay after
that he took too much time and he just
basically destroyed his own position he
had a quite a good opening position well
I played some dubious moves but he
played positional yeah well then you get
your your classes tonight how many more
games do you think you got in you know
well this is this is something new Jeff
I'd like one or two more oh yeah yeah so
we'll do this then we'll do we do two
more probably after this
last chances to get your your challenges
and
yeah probably won't be playing any 1000
and hopefully people in the back are
looking for good people to raid we gotta
get into the rating business hopefully
there's just someone else just starting
on Twitch that we like if we can raid
I've ever heard of this Gio he's
crushing the people that's right
it's the highest-rated opponent you've
played besides of your own Club question
to both of you I've played with like we
said in three world champions I mean so
it's they were not exactly from my club
so I've played one fall in peds
I've paid with put a lot of like one
like 61 international tournament in
which there were great masters at least
you know so yeah there were good players
if only Grandmaster I played in already
gamers it's been fine gold but that's
when he was here at the club outside of
the club I've played a lot of IMS but no
no grandmasters
hey I like Knights yay I like my it's
too generous
okay
no it's good
that looks good
it's a long one I wouldn't have to
scooch in closer
yeah yeah Julian saying everyone gave
honor the chat was accusing him of
cheating in that game but I suspected
nothing yeah I guess he had some
troubles on the light rest over there
that's what is the wait time in between
the moves was
yeah many people were just jumping on
the bandwagon sometimes fun to accuse
people of cheating without any evidence
hey come in am i interrupting no we only
had a couple games left come say hey
sorry
no don't be sorry come and interrupt us
yeah you got to be here yeah we're all
friends around this place just do a
little bit of cleaning okay
listen Ben Simon I'm just doing is what
are you cleaning the screens clean this
one he's got like 40 seconds so you
probably well he was like good I think I
think he's got enough time there that's
good enough position if you could just
polish it up I don't know this looks
Josh oh okay let me say two more yeah
okay so we'll do this and then we'll do
one more after this
Jonathan have you told the people about
the ladies tonight yeah we're talking
Emily was in here Emily was all talking
about a eight o'clock yeah it was gonna
be tuning in so yeah they'll go away
we'll give you guys time to go do
whatever you got to go do and then
they'll come back and eat and actually
before then at 7:00 we are premiering a
lecture which one is it time do you know
it is going to be a Romantic era yeah
sure mr. :
awesome from last Thursday evening so
people have time to check that out and
then immediately after that they can
join the ladies night stream yeah if
you're on YouTube you can just stay on
YouTube or you can go to twitch for the
stream whatever you want the YouTube
premier though is only gonna be on
YouTube starts at 7:00 awesome that's
real good
alright do you know anything about the
ladies and I think that if we don't know
coz what do you need to know well is is
Danny playing is question number one
also is it mostly Emily playing is there
a little girl playing yeah what's it all
about
so I obviously don't know so every
Thursday night every Thursday night here
at the Chess Club we have a class called
ladies night and it is typically a
beginner class for ladies who just want
to learn the game
of their own there's no pressure a lot
of them are friends and I think they get
wine and cheese too yeah so that's
really great mm-hmm so the idea is let's
keep them here a little bit longer and
have them play online chess right so the
first week when I understand what I
understand is I guess I better talk to
you since I don't have a mic or knob you
won the whole tickets just want to just
shout the first week it's going to be
Emily Trask in here hosting I believe
okay
and she'll be playing with one of the
youngest players in late-night who I
believe is seven years in ren-tv we're
talking about yesterday and so that
should be a very fun experience we'll
see how many people are going to lose
tonight to a seven-year-old it's gonna
be an amazing night here at the Chess
Club yeah I can't wait
so yeah they'll definitely be fun to see
all right I'm not to see if they have
fun hopefully they hopefully you can
maintain our our new rating that the G
I'm just pumped up
all right so much chat going on what if
I missed main lady and will he be
wearing a dress five missions to be a GM
interesting all my questions streams
underrated C pieces just an empty board
awesome stream will should be the next
will chess champion mmm-hmm I don't know
we'll have to see sometimes it takes
them to like twelve to get really good
it's hard to know where did your beard
go no same length yeah number two on the
razor yeah yeah yeah do behave people
are already starting to act up a bit do
behave in the chat we want this ladies
night thing to be a success we do
appreciate always whenever you guys are
here doing a good job
I'm not Isaac yeah Mary that is the
confusion a lot of people confuse this
yeah you do mix up the two that's funny
will she be playing bullet no idea
you'll have to wait till 8 o'clock to
see ya know it is a lot to ask to behave
in a twitch chat for some reason you
guys do it for us hopefully you do it
tonight please don't destroy the show
first episode do you guys know any
Brazilian songs no all right good stuff
probably be asleep what I assume I
assume they'll be away if it all goes
well to see it on YouTube so he probably
mostly up to you guys don't mess it up I
want to be able to see it on YouTube
Twitter I hope she says I'm crushing
after every move yeah she's really
adorable girl and she's a obviously for
for her age she's phenomenal chess
player so it'll be interesting to see
her and hopefully and he's a good chance
to even if stuff you're like a beginner
adult it'll actually be really cool to
see if she can beat some of you guys
are we talking about your ladies night
at eight our new show there's gonna be a
seven-year-old little girl was the the
daughter of one of our instructors and
yeah she's decent at chess so I hope to
see her beat some people all right so is
this our last one here
yeah that's King chaser it's not to
finish up our show for today at least I
was king will be kissed
yeah let's go Jason can you just go
checkmate somebody for once it's just
like checkmate him
well yeah we won't quite cross the 2100
threshold wait for a little Evie to come
here and push us over
what time is it there it is 4:30 so yeah
that means 8 will be in mmm let's say
three and a half hours yeah doll the
pieces Adam that's what I'm talking
about
just go check minam yeah we're just
gonna win slowly yeah I barely knows the
rules as a prodigy sounds about right
are we not featured on the HS webpage
yeah that's upsetting yeah we usually
are twelve hours difference for four
tarik yes hopefully some of you guys get
to see it obviously if you can't see it
if it all goes well we'll throw it up on
YouTube but just in case it goes really
bad you do want to see a life if you
have the opportunity anyway it's guy
Emily Trask in it how bad could it be
[Music]
we are on the leech s homepage perfect
for our nights okay it may be another
one all right we gotta let the Knights
do their thing okay no hurry up we're
just scared to jump no that's why they
call them
Oh mr. jumpy again yeah I don't think
they do the big blue button for just the
normal twitch streams what's her twitch
name sto Chess Club maybe
now the problem is the nighttime sir
this is a real this is yeah formed we
ant a little bit on the low level but
that's why we get more Forks this is
real life in real life you know you play
1900 before come that's what happens
oh good yeah somebody became a better
chess player
watching a tennis we're glad to hear it
yeah turning another Fork d6 let's see
what's happening yeah
let's insist he doesn't want all right
let's put things are possible but okay
we teach the kids that we have to put
rooks on open files and then if we don't
put them yeah it's kind of they feel
they feel embarrassed for us no Raymond
I don't believe either you're a very
master you barely know the rules
mmm-hmm okay I'm going to take no really
I mean I can't do anything about it I
just have to do it
and here I also have to play this much I
mean no I have to play this move like to
look at this
doesn't mean enough
[Music]
too much of this stuff yeah if you guys
are are here you'll be doing the classes
tonight yes yes we'll be doing the
viewers choice we'll be looking at games
and then the Romantic era we'll continue
with one of my favorite players from the
19th century because I think that they
were just geniuses because they had to
invent almost all of the ideas were
using today and of course I like most of
the incredible players for all year but
from 19th centuries they are not only
incredible chess players but they really
knew what these words which nowadays we
have sometimes to look at the vocabulary
like honor like you know to keep your
word they really knew what they meant I
should like to is a part of understand
when there was some dispute they just
have to ask him in whatever he says this
was like the truth so these are really
some gentlemen on of the chest broad and
they really made the foundation for us
to be able nowadays in the modern time
to enjoy chess yeah surely people check
that out hopefully the people in the
back there are actually thinking if
caleb is actually streaming let's write
him otherwise there's like some other
people there that we can read and then
so we'll check that out
eight o'clock you guys do definitely
want to be here to check out the the
brand-new ladies night thing and who
knows what's gonna happen I'm gonna be
tuning in I'm gonna try to check it out
if I get the chance
yeah so we'll see what happens there and
then I want to thank you again Atanas
for doing another brilliant stream thank
you the audience and hope to meet you
very soon here on the truth broke all
right thanks everybody have a good night
thanks buddy all right you guys super
raid somebody